Paul has the option between a high
deductible or a low or a low deductible
health insurance plan and when we talk
about the deductible and health
insurance if someone says that they have
a plan with a thousand dollar deductible
that means that the insurance company
only pays a medical costs after the
first thousand dollars so if you have a
thousand dollar deductible and you say
incur medical costs of $800 you're going
to pay that $800 the insurance company
won't pay anything if your deductible of
$1,000 and your total medical costs are
twelve hundred you're going to pay the
first thousand and then the insurance
company will kick in after that so with
that out of the way let's think about
his two plans if Paul chooses the low
deductible plan he will have to pay the
first thousand dollars of any let me do
that in purple the first thousand
dollars of any medical costs the low
deductible plan costs eight thousand
dollars for a year so in this situation
he's gonna pay eight thousand dollars to
get the insurance if he has nine hundred
dollars of medical expenses the
insurance company still pays nothing if
he is two thousand dollars of medical
expenses then he pays the first thousand
and then the insurance company would pay
the next thousand if he has ten thousand
and medical expenses he would pay the
first thousand and then the insurance
company would pay the next nine thousand
if Paul chooses a high deductible plan
he will have to pay the first 2500 of
any medical costs the high deductible
plan costs 7,500 a year and it makes
sense that the high deductible plan
costs less than the low deductible plan
because here the insurance doesn't kick
in until he has over $2,500 of medical
expenses while here was only a thousand
to help himself choose a plan Paul found
some statistics about common health
problems for people similar to him
assumed at the table below and I put it
up here on the right
correctly shows the probabilities and
costs of total medical incidents within
the next year so this right over here
it's saying what's the probability is
zero in medical cost what's the
probability of well he has a 25%
probability of $1000 20% probably four
thousand dollars and this is a
simplification a pretty dramatic
simplification from the real world and
the real world
the way this makes it sound is there's
only five possible medical costs that
someone might have zero one thousand
four thousand seven thousand to fifteen
thousand in the real world you could
have twenty dollars in medical costs you
could have twenty thousand you could
have nine hundred ninety nine dollars so
in the real world there's many many more
situations here that you would have to
kind of redistribute the probabilities
accordingly but what that said this
isn't a bad approximation it's just
saying okay you know roughly if that is
the if you if you if you wanted to
construct this so it's easier to do the
math which which the problem writers
have done say look okay 30% zero 25%
$1000 this is pretty indicative if you
had to kind of group all of the possible
costs into some major into some major
buckets so it's probably at least a
pretty good method for figuring out
which insurance policy someone should
use so this including the cost of
insurance
what are Paul's expected total medical
costs with the low deductible plan
round your answer to the nearest cent so
actually I'll get the calculator out for
this so at the low whoops
with the low deductible plan here low
deductible plan he's going to have to
spend his total cost he's gonna spend
eight thousand no matter what eight
whoops what happened to my calculator
he's gonna spend eight thousand Mike I'm
having issues he's gonna spend eight
thousand no matter no matter what
so that is eight thousand dollars and
then let's see there's a 30% probability
he has spends nothing I could just write
that as plus 0.3 times zero and I will
write it just so that you see I'm taking
that into account and there's a 25%
chance that he has a thousand dollars in
medical costs and the low deductible
plan he starts to pay that thousand
dollars so plus 0.25 percent chance that
he pays $1,000 $1,000 and then you might
say okay plus 0.2 times 4,000 but
remember if if his costs are four if his
medical costs are four thousand he's not
going to pay that four thousand he's
only going to pay the first thousand
so it's really plus point to in this
situation his out-of-pocket costs are
only $1,000 the insurance company will
pay will pay the next three thousand so
0.2 times a thousand
and then plus plus point to 20% chance
even if he has seven thousand in medical
costs
he's only have to pay he's only going to
have to pay the first thousand so 0.2
times a thousand again and then plus
0.05 times once again a thousand if he
has 15,000 expenses he's only going to
have to pay the first thousand times one
thousand and we get eight thousand seven
hundred dollars and one way you could
have thought about it is okay he's gonna
have to pay eight thousand eight
thousand dollars no matter what and the
all of the situations where he ends up
where he ends up paying that's anything
that's these four situations right over
here there's a 70% probability of
falling into one of these four
situations and in any one of these he
only has to pay a thousand dollars the
insurance company pays everything after
that
so you could say eight thousand plus
there's a 70% chance that he's going to
pay one thousand and once again this is
kind of this tables a it's a pretty big
simplification from from the real world
there's probably a lot of scenarios
where you would have to pay $500 or $600
or whatever it might be but let's just
go with this and so that's essentially a
simplification there's a 70 percent
chance that he's going to have to pay a
thousand dollars and so that's a $700
expected cost from that plus the 8,000
from the insurance gets us to eighty
seven eighty seven hundred dollars so
let's let's write that down so eighty
seven eighty seven hundred my pen is
really acting up I don't know what's
going on here I think I have to get a
new tablet maybe you can't even read
that let me write this 87 whoops
$8,700 including the cost of insurance
what our pauls expect
total medical costs with the high
deductible plan round your answer to the
nearest cent so let's look at the high
deductible plan so he's gonna pay 7,500
no matter what 7,500 no matter what and
then in so there's a zero we could write
zero dollars times 30% or 30% times zero
dollars but that's just going to be zero
there's a 25% chance he spends a
thousand dollars
so plus 0.25 times 1,000 there's a 20%
chance plus 0.2 he's not gonna spend
4000 here he's going to spend the first
2500 so it's a 20% chance he spends 2500
so times 2500 insurance company will pay
the next 1500 plus another 20% chance
even in this situation he only has to
pay 2500 so times 2500 2500 and then
finally plus there's a 5% chance even in
this situation he only has to pay the
first 2500 times
2500 gets us to eight thousand eight
hundred and seventy-five dollars so
eight thousand eight hundred and
seventy-five seventy-five dollars and
once again you could think about it as
okay there's a 25% chance that he pays a
thousand and then there is a forty five
percent chance that he pays $2,500 all
of these situations he's paying $2,500
but either way you would get eight
thousand eight hundred and seventy five
if Paul wants the best pay off in the
long run and must buy one of the two
insurance plans he should purchase the
well his expected total cost of medical
of cost of insurance including medical
costs is lower with the low deductible
plan so this one he should go the low
low deductible low deductible which once
again you know you shouldn't use these
videos as kind of insurance advice this
is actually but else it's an interesting
way to think about it it's typically
what
not always typically the case at the low
deductible plan it's going to have a
higher long-term or the low deductible
plan it's going to have a is going to be
a better deal it's usually the well I
won't I want making the actuarial
statements but at least in this
situation the low deductible plan seems
like the better deal he has lower
expected total costs given these
probabilities